Do you notice a big difference between like female athletes and male athletes?
Like,
okay.
Cause fighting is a pretty,
I don't want to say exaggerated,
but it's an interesting thing where
okay,
you know,
you have men and women kind of differently,
but doing the same thing if you will.
Yeah.
Um,
do you notice a difference in their mentality?
MMM,
well they vary so much individually.
That's what's interesting.
It's like you'll find even male fighters who are like super laid back and then
you find other ones that are really intense and super emotional and uh,
it's really hard to tell.
Like there's a,
there's Gunnar Nelson is a guy from Iceland,
you know,
is,
I know who he is.
Yeah.
But fantastic Jiujitsu guy.
You cannot get that guy to change his expression.
It doesn't change.
You could punch him,
kick him in the balls.
He stay stoic.
It's a weird,
he's a weird guy.
Yeah.
He's very on one side of it.
And then there's like guys like Conor Mcgregor who's also his training partner
who's on a completely different side of it.
He's screaming and yelling and talking shit to everybody.
And you know,
that's,
that's part of his flair.
You know,
they vary so widely.
And that's true with girls too.
Some girls are brash and outrageous and they get another girl's faces and put
their knuckles on their nose and they were at the stare down and other girls bow
and the hug and they take selfies together.
It's like everyone has their own sort of approach to it.
It's very interesting.
It is interesting.
I'm always,
I'm,
I'm in fighting and intrigues me in that.
I think it's interesting that you're trying to be offensive and defensive at the
same time,
dealing with fear,
like all these things happening simultaneously.
And I then take it,
I look at it one step further with a female because
I don't know,
I,
I'm interested to know how,
if,
if a female can fight from a,
not,
not a nonemotional place,
but without her emotion.
Like just like,
okay,
I'm in my mail,
I'm in my athlete and um,
I'm not going to be like,
oh,
she didn't just kick me in the ear,
you know,
and like freak out.
You know what I mean?
Like,
cause I think about myself and I'd be like,
you know,
like I,
I've only been in one fight in my whole life and,
and the girl hit me in the face and when I saw my blood I was like,
oh no,
she did not just hit me in the face,
you know,
and then went crazy.
But if these girls could be like,
cause they're so well trained as an athlete,
how that can supersede or override actually like this im that feminine impulse
of like a,
you know,
reaction,
a reaction.
That's a masculine impulse to though I think it's a human impulse.
If a guy punches you in the face,
you get furious.
It's so hard for people to not get emotional when they get hit.
Yeah.
Cause he wanted to get it back.
That's a good point.
It's a very bad way to react in a fight to fight with emotions because you
expose yourself,
right.
You leave yourself open for counters.
You Do,
you miss your rhythm.
You're not as deceptive and your,
your emotions,
you're too obvious in your pattern.
And so many times you,
you get hit a lot more.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a big problem with fighters.
That emotion.
It's a very big problem.
And uh,
the wanting to break people,
like letting them hit you so that you could show them that they can't hurt you
to get some masculine thing too stupid.
It's a very stupid,
take it on the face on purpose and then just like,
come on,
come on.
Hit.
That's what you have.
Yeah.
Then that's a terrible emotion though,
cause you can get completely knocked unconscious doing that happens all the
time.
It's just the smart thing to do is to fight with correct technique and with a
correct strategy.
Meaning you have an understanding of how to execute best.
It's not to just wait and let bombs fly.
It's,
you have to,
you have to be very precise in your tactics.
You've got to be very smart.
I think it's interesting though,
um,
those sports where there is that,
I mean,
listen,
versions of it is football.
You know,
living with layered,
obviously,
you know,
he always says he appreciates mother nature because it's like you make good
decisions.
You're rewarded,
you make bad decisions.
You,
you pay a price.
But I think it is very interesting when you have two humans strategically trying
to deconstruct one another.
Um,
the chess,
the physical chest that goes on as like looking at it from another athlete's
point of view.
Um,
I think it's a unique person that wants to put themselves in that situation.
You know,
it's like,
I understand almost like,
uh,
you know,
a surfer and a wave and a rock climber and a mountain.
I get that.
Like I'm going to be a part of that.
Um,
but I find it really interesting and even sort of,
I'm even more curious about women,
like who say like,
yeah,
this is going to be my sport
wildly.
Uh,
like there's Holly Holm.
She
just seems like awfully sweet.
She seemed like she'd bring you cupcakes or murder.
You just kick your fuck.
I saw the pack.
I mean,
listen,
I saw that kick,
but then it's like,
I'm so sorry I made you these after,
you know,
chocolate chip cookies.
It's like,
okay,
I'll get it.
You know,
when I come back from the hospital,
um,
I don't know.
It's,
it is interesting when you see girls like that.
Yeah.
Well,
they're all different.
I always want to know,
do they have brothers,
like where they rabble rousing and that their whole time and it wasn't,
and they learn to play in,
it wasn't personal,
you know,
and like a little contact was,
okay.